fue muy trágica fue
muy consternado como esta como esta
noticia realmente estamos en la
filmación de una película con al
alakrana y yo tenía que entrar
disparando disparo y quiero a mi
compañero
con el arma de fuego que me que me
dieron supuestamente de utilería a
grandes rasgos es eso ahora a raíz de su
caso flavio hubo algún tipo de cambio en
méxico en términos de protocolos de
seguridad en filmaciones con armas
no simplemente que siempre ha habido
este protocolo y se supone que un arma
para cine y salvas para cine no lastiman
al compañero a mí me han disparado con
la arma pegada al cuerpo y no y no no
nunca me ha pasado nada
entonces no era un arma de utilería la
que tenía usted en sus manos finalmente
era era un arma era un revólver
no era una escuadra que son las que se
arreglan para para cine pero era un
revolver con el cañón obturado pero la
salva que se utilizó era hechiza
entonces estaba tapada con un cartón con
barniz que ese cartón con barniz se
convierte en un proyectil al momento de
detonar el arma ahora pasó un tiempo
hasta que usted volviera usted a los
sets de filmación que sintió cuando
regresó
afortunadamente regresé casi
inmediatamente
me sentí raro al agarrar un arma pero
realmente mis compañeros
me ayudaron a hacerlo y lo hice lo bueno
fue que soy inmediata y cómo fue ese
proceso desde los hechos me refiero a
nivel judicial y a nivel de la
investigación
a nivel judicial aquí en méxico fue un
poco difícil porque yo me imagino que
tanto el director como el fotógrafo
tuvieron miedo y escondieron la película
y escondieron el sonido un gran tiempo y
eso
hizo que se crearan una incertidumbre
entonces de eso fue y medio fue tedioso
un poco duró 14 años el juicio aquí en
méxico esto por supuesto me imagino lo
habrá marcado a nivel personal pero como
lo marcó a nivel profesional digo se
maneja usted de una manera diferente a
que anterior a estos hechos
no simplemente pongo un poquito más de
atención en
el armero cuando se acerca a mí revisa
el arma en frente de mí
y cuando me la quita es inmediatamente
terminando la escena recogen el arma y
la revisan también ellos pilares
abastecen la desabastecía en si uno
tiene que seguir con el arma la
desabastecen y uno sigue con el arma y
son los protocolos que siempre se han
seguido
la experiencia muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24